top three countries and tourism the 70s
you ready yeah burma
cuba iran
and it's crazy how those countries
have completely
done yeah now frank sinatra would go
perform there all the time zahidi was
dating elizabeth taylor
iran was like the place rich people went
to like yeah about where rich people go
to today we're going to go to dubai way
before there was dubai it was tehran
iran you'd go then you'd go to bandar
pahlavi which is a different port of
palavi by caspian sea which you would
have caviar as if it's just regular
you're having coffee so then
the the mullahs or whoever was basically
saying all right this is enough's enough
here yeah
what was that you if you were there for
10 years you must have
you probably don't speak the language
but you must have
sensed some
unease like okay this is the like what
pat is basically describing is the paris
of the middle east and that's where rich
people are going but there must be this
undercurrent of people not digging this
vibe clearly did you sense any of that
what was that situation like that's
what's shocking is no i didn't sense it
i don't know that anybody sensed it i've
become friends since then with bob baer
you may know him the cia guy that the
movie syrian is based on he was he was
deep undercover spoke farsi as well as
arabic
i don't think he was even i mean i don't
get how
how difficult it was for us to
understand what's going on i understand
for me
that all the information i got came from
translators who worked for the shah you
know and they've all been
they've all been screwed so they're
sweeping things under the rug
everything's fine look this way don't
worry have a drink have some fun i you
know i would ask to interview some of
the poor people and and so on and so
forth but i always had a translator
because they didn't speak english and i
don't know what was translated correctly
and you know i know that the same is
true around the world you get a lot of
misinformation if you don't speak the
language you know i find one of the
reasons latin america was so
enlightening for me in torrijos because
i spoke spanish right but in iran no i
there was we had no english iran was the
only country
uh at the time even it was saudi arabia
well our contract in saudi arabia was
actually the u.s treasury department to
build stuff in saudi arabia that's
another story but i think iran was the
only country from where my company
did not require
advanced payment for the work that we
did we trusted iran to pay its debts to
add the money yeah and when as a result
we lost millions of dollars when the
shot went down because they owed us a
lot of money which we never collected
because we took we totally trusted them
so it is shocking to me how
how little we understood has has any
country
taken a bigger 180 than iran because
what he's basically saying venezuela
would be in the top five because
venezuela used to be
a modern-day iran you're talking about a
country that has the most supply of oil
oil natural resources yeah of course and
it was a beautiful place to go to next
to colombia a great place iran and they
also have beautiful women they also know
how to party they also know how to put
it together they also know how to you
know have fun
and iran did so as well but iran but but
venezuela i wouldn't put them on on the
same level as iran iran is working on
nuclear missiles
yeah but during the time during that
time
this guy
had a deal originally british petroleum
right was in iran bp prior to that it
was called the anglo something something
you know persian oil company you know so
it was a
britain had a chokehold on iran
and they pretty much ran everything in
iran until mossader which was somebody
that you know his
uh i don't know if you dealt with
mosaddegh's issue i think other people
from the deck was the early 50s
you were still a kid
was a guy he most of that would have
been the modern-day bernie sanders he
was a socialist and he wanted to take
the oil money from iran and give it to
everybody and he didn't like the fact
that the rich people were getting richer
and all this stuff and he came in
and he he kind of wanted to negotiate
stuff with oil but he wasn't strong
enough to negotiate
and then zahidi which you know you know
who's ideas uh
he was the ambassador of u.s zahadi was
a very powerful man
um and jose also yeah i would say that
as well but zahidi was how would you
describe zahidi he was
he like he dated elizabeth taylor zahidi
was like if he was a g a young zahidi
a young
no way tyler spells this right
there's a z there's an h there might be
a lowercase q it's zero it's not d tyler
can you get this right so hundred bucks
if you spell this right on the first 100
bucks i'll give you a thousand
bucks but
a r d e he went to a point side
a-r-d-s-h-i-r
and then put
z-a-h-e-d-i
okay
uh young okay go to images go to images
and this guy was like
the right to click on that one that one
right there is fine he's a guy in the
top left maybe that's a bad picture for
him but every look who it is on the
right do you see what he's on there
beetle i can't really see who is that on
the right is that barbra streisand i
think that's barbra streisand yeah
zahidi uh uh it's crazy what's the date
on that article washington post can you
click on it flamboyant iranian
ambassador
okay
died
at 93 what age is that can you get that
uh get rid of that no that's so you can
i'll go back and see when he just died
because it has to be in the last 18
months and this was who was he in iran
he is he's the guy you go through if you
want to do any dealings with the shot so
this guy comes in
he creates uh a campaign together he's
like the chief of staff basically let me
tell you this guy is the shot cup he is
he's a very important guy got it he gets
rid of musa in a way i mean a lot of
people say he got rid of mosaddegh but
can he see when he died i want to know
when he dies it has to be in the last 18
months he gets rid of mozart oh really
shaw comes in i was supposed to
interview him he was sick when i was
supposed to interview him see when he
died i was supposed to eat i think he
was living in switzerland or sweden
something like that november 18th of
last year that's
look at his birthday you know he's a
special gamer it's october 16 two days
apart he died four months three months i
know he just died i'm telling you i had
a schedule go to switzerland
mario we got on a call with the guy he
sent me an autograph of his book saying
i'm looking forward to the interview
because we were going to have some
interesting conversations together but
unfortunately he died do you see who his
wife was his first his wife stood up
until 1964.
yeah you know who that is well paula v
is pretty well known well-known
and you know he he's he's lucky because
jovaita who was prime minister and and i
got to know quite well
uh was
executed he was he was shot by we don't
know whether it was a firing squad or
whether somebody shot him just before
he's surprised he lived islam yeah
that's what i'm saying he he's lucky he
made it because
right after the revolution was put on
trial and found guilty of all kinds of
things no question about it this
khomeini was after this guy for a
longest time everybody was like this
guy's not going to make you no he's but
he made it to 93 legit respect for him
too make it that long by the way this
guy was the encyclopedia of everything
that took place during that time if
there's if there's a guy that knew it
was this guy so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]